okay hi everyone so I'm going to do
another science and technology Q&A
intended for kids and some others but
mostly for kids and a particular topic
today is about how things work so don't
guarantee to be able to answer all of
these but um ask me what if you want and
I'll do my best and logistically we will
be going for just a little bit over an
hour here and not longer than that um
great
so who wants to start off here let's see
we seem to have a up something coming
here how the antibodies work okay let's
see if I can can say something about
that so the this is about the human
immune system and it's some the the the
basic problem of that the immune system
is trying to solve is when some foreign
intruder comes into one's body how do we
notice it and how do we get rid of it
and the the basic idea is we every cell
in our body has a DNA sequence and every
cell that's in us has the same DNA
sequence so I think we have maybe a
hundred trillion cells in our bodies and
every one of those cells the way that it
knows how to produce proteins that make
muscle or hair or skin or heart cells or
whatever is through this program that's
specified in this DNA molecule and so
every time a new cell is produced it
comes with a copy of the DNA molecule
from whatever cells it came from and
actually a human DNA molecule if you
stretch it all the way out it would be a
single molecule that's about a meter
long
um and that um
that that DNA molecule that's what says
how you should build the things that we
want in the cells in our body okay so
any intruder any living intruder like a
bacterium or a virus it has its own DNA
actually some viruses like the corona
virus have RNA which is kind of like
half of the DNA but it's the same idea
they have their own RNA or DNA and they
have their own instructions their own
program for what the for what the for
for how to make the things that will
make a new virus or make pieces of a
bacterium or something like this and so
sort of the the fundamental problem of
the immune system is if you see a cell
in your body and that cell has a certain
RNA or DNA in it tell whether that's
your owner DNA or whether that's a
foreign intruders DNA now it's a little
bit more complicated immediately because
for example of virus what it does is it
tries to take over the the apparatus
inside a cell that makes things proteins
and things inside the cell and that's
all happening inside the cell and
there's an issue of the fact that the
immune system can only get to see things
on the surface of a cell um and so
that's a that's that's sort of one of
the challenges for the immune system is
it only gets to see what's on the
surface of a cell whereas when a virus
infects a cell it's going into the
center of the cell and starting to try
to take over that what's happening
inside the cell okay so so and as I say
the the and the program that is in our
DNA it's about six billion base pairs
long so if you go look at a piece of a
sequence from DNA it'll read you know
ATG see there are these four letters a T
C and G and it's some long combination
of those letters and that long
combination of letters is the program
that makes us for example this corona
virus that we're all fighting right now
it
program is it's an RNAi program and it's
just 29 thousand base pairs long um so
the question that we have is given a
given our genome and given the genome of
well actually you know what I'm gonna
actually show you something I'm going to
show you something
I can pull this in let's see what I can
do this just for a second I'm not sure
if this is gonna work but I'm gonna give
it a try I thought let me actually pull
in maybe this is too difficult that may
be I'm sorry I'm not going to I'm not
gonna try and do this I was going to
actually pull in on my computer the the
genome for the coronavirus and the human
genome and I was going to look at where
there start to be overlap so for example
if we say if our immune system said if
ever we see ay ay ay ay ay in our in on
Appetit
genome of particular cell then it must
be bad it wouldn't say that because
probably a AAA let me find out I just go
look this up or from alpha has a
convenient way of just I'm gonna make
let's say a GT a GT a GTCC okay so
that's a that's a particular sequence on
the genome and what what Wolfram Alpha
is telling us is it says there might be
as many as 1500 matches on the human
genome to that particular sequence here
let me actually I'm gonna share this
just for the hell of it um hold on okay
there we go
so let me make this a lot bigger all
right so I just asked it this is a
possible little piece of program from
from a genome so there let me let me ask
you about that sequence okay so what
this says is on the human genome that
particular sequence of A's and B's and
C's and so on never appears in the image
genome so if we ever saw that inside us
we would know it was an intruder okay
let me let me just change this a bit let
me let me make it a bit shorter and
chances are if we have a shorter
sequence okay so there we go so that
particular sequence if we saw that
sequence there well actually that
sequence occurs in human genome it's
let's look at what it is it seems to
occur twice in the human genome
once on the X chromosome once on
chromosome 2 just give you a sense of
how this works this gene is a little sub
program on the genome and let's find out
what FTC dnl 1 what that gene actually
is see what it says Oh didn't know it
was more interpretations human gene
let's see what that no it doesn't know
what it is ok well let's try this one
here um ok this is something very
obscure ok
I don't know what this is this is a
mammalian retro transposon derived
protein for zinc finger domain
containing protein 6 so that's a little
piece of the machine code of how we work
that's a little program that makes a
particular protein that does something I
don't know I actually do know what this
means but it's not doesn't really help
me this is this is like telling me that
this is part of the you know part of the
input-output system that deals with
reading you know events from the
keyboard or something if it was a
computer but this is actually for a for
an organism for humans okay but so this
is something where if we saw so we go
back to that sequence again so that's
what if we see this sequence here then
this sequence is something that yes that
can appear will appear in the human
genome so if you see that on a cell in
as humans leave it alone it's fine it's
a it's a it's a human cell it's all good
but on the other hand if you see some
other sequence it will be a sequence
where you can say no couldn't possibly
occur in the human genome must be an
intruder and once you say once you
notice it must be an intruder then the
goal of the immune system is going an
intruder kill off that cell get rid of
it from our bodies okay so um let me go
ahead here stop showing that so so
that's so that's kind of the objective
of the immune system is is it a a piece
of genome that's from us which means
it's okay or a piece of genome that's
from the intruder which means it isn't
okay alright so how on earth does it
tell that it's quite clever so what it's
doing is it has well the full mechanism
are all complicated but but basically we
are remembering in these things called
b-cells we're remembering sequences that
are that we have noticed before our
intruder sequences and so for example
when you get the your IgG level measured
if you if you get an antibody test for
the corona virus what it will do is it
will measure the level of IgG
immunoglobulin G in your blood and a
particular immunoglobulin G it's it's
the one that encodes a sequence that
comes from the the the corona virus and
so what's happening is your immune
system in that case knows if you see
that sequence it is bad go attack it in
the case where it hasn't seen the virus
before it hasn't seen one of those
intruders before takes the immune system
awhile the immune system is always
generating collections of possible
antibodies and it's trying to figure out
are those um well okay I I should
explain how the antibodies work I'm the
ah boy this whole mechanism a little
complicated actually um what is
ultimately going to happen is again the
key idea is is the sequence that you see
a sequence that is a human sequence or
an intruder sequence and by the way when
you get autoimmune diseases like asthma
or type 1 diabetes one of these kinds of
things what's happening is that your
immune system is deciding to be
overactive and is saying that sequence
that you know there's a sequence that
I'm seeing and actually that sequence is
is one that I think is an intruder
even though really it's it's some it's a
sequence that is is really just an OK
human sequence and and the way things
work is the the question of what's a you
sequence of what's another sequence
that's that's encoded actually the way
it works is I think of the thymus gland
which is something that is very active
woman's younger stopped by the time
you're as old as me it's it's probably
doing absolutely absolutely nothing but
it's the thing that learns when you're
young what cells what the sequences that
correspond to you are and what and by
sort of exclusion it knows what
sequences don't correspond to you but so
so what happens is the the goal well ok
little complicated here because the the
the antibodies are things that will
attach themselves to cells that are
found to be intruder cells and the
antibodies have little things that are
like genetic sequences on them that say
if there's a cell like this that has has
a sequence like this then this antibody
will attach to that cell and once the
cell has been tagged with antibodies
then the immune system knows to sort of
bring out its big guns and try and try
and kill off that cell the it's a little
bit complicated because when you
generate antibodies the the immune
system has to be careful to not generate
too many antibodies and so it tends to
have some system which is
not particularly well understood where
you generate antibodies to some antigens
some intruder sequence and then there
are anti antibodies generated but kind
of kick down the level of antibodies at
least that's what people think happens
and of all the possible so what what if
you look at the the the way that
antibodies work they are looking at that
they're asking the question does a
particular chunk of genome sequence
occur so again what length is it I don't
remember I think it may be length 9 may
be length 12 I can't remember but
there's a they're little short sequences
and because of the way the math works
out by the time you have a length 12
sequence for example you can be pretty
certain whether that sequence is a human
sequence or not there are enough
different possibilities for that
sequence that if if it's that that it
either is a human sequence or it isn't a
human sequence you don't it won't be a
human sequence by chance so to speak and
so what then has to happen is these
these antibodies have their own sort of
variability and they can connect to
these they they will notice these little
short sequences and they're about I
think they're about a hundred billion
different kinds of antibodies that can
exist and when you develop antibodies
for a particular virus what's happening
is that some of those antibodies are
ones whose sequences match the sequences
of that virus and will be the things
that will then mark cells that are
infected with that virus so that the
rest of the immune system can go attack
it that's that's roughly it's a very
rough version of how antibodies work the
you know there's sort of a famous
picture of antibodies it's kind of a
y-shaped molecule and there's a region
on the antibodies so called hyper
variable region that is the part of the
antibody that has has very variable
things in it that is used to kind of
match the sequences in the intruders
that exist in your cells and and the way
it cells cells have a mechanism for sort
of taking the stuff that's inside
and grinding it up in his all short
sequences and exposing them on the
surface of the cell so that the immune
system can kind of go check cells and
find out whether they have anything bad
going on inside them there's a thing
called the NHC the major
histocompatibility complex which is
let's see you are testing my my
knowledge of this but there's a that
that's what ends up being let's see that
that's that's part of the mechanism for
exposing fragments of of things that are
contained within a cell on the surface
of the cell so the immune system can go
and check them out so to speak all right
that was a sorry that was a little bit
that's it's only complicated mechanism
and there's I left out a lot of details
and explaining that but maybe that gives
some idea of how things work all right
next question we have here is what's the
relationship between electricity and
magnetism okay this is something was
discovered in the 1800s and the I can
tell you sort of the the main the main
story here so electricity is in
something like a wire is a flow of
electrons so electrons are little
particles that are what are inside atoms
but electrons are also what make
electricity electricity is made of a
large numbers of electrons each electron
has a little amount of electric charge
an electric current is the flow of
electrons so that's like you have all
these electrons and if they're and
they're moving down a wire and that
motion of charge from one place to
another is electric current and so what
one usually talked the woman talks about
electricity one's usually talking about
this the flow of electrons the flow of
these of these electric charges for
example down a wire okay so that's
that's sort of the basic idea of what
electricity is what is magnetism
well magnetism so you might say so
magnetism is is what for example
you get in a magnet and in a magnet
what's what's what one way to get
magnetism is to have electricity for
example if you have an electric current
that's going around in a circle then it
the it's just a fact about physics that
an electric current going around in a
circle produces a magnetic field
produces magnetism where the the
magnetism is kind of corresponds to
something where okay so where the
magnetism is if the electric current is
going around in that circle where
there's a magnetic field that goes up
this way how do you notice a magnetic
field if you get for example iron
filings just iron ground up into little
powder and you put them around a magnet
then they will arrange themselves and
the magnetic field lines and they'll
look like a thing where where there's
the magnet the magnet is here then the
field lines will come out and go around
like that so the magnet so for example a
magnet has a North Pole and a South Pole
let's say they just called that because
the earth has a magnetic field the earth
is like a giant magnet and the that
there are these lines of magnetic force
that go from North Pole to South Pole
for example so you might ask the
question one question you might ask is
well electrons are the sort of smallest
components of electricity what are the
smallest components of magnetism so
electrons have an electric charge you
might say well is there a magnetic
charge
that's like electric charge that sort of
makes magnetism the answer is no doesn't
appear to be the case in our universe
there is a theoretical kind of particle
called a magnetic monopole which would
be the magnetic analog of an electron
will be something that makes magnetic
field like an electron makes electric
field it was something that has a
magnetic charge like an electron has an
electric charge so far as we know
magnetic monopoles do not exist the laws
of physics don't
allow magnetic monopoles to exist and
when you have a magnet it always has
like a North Pole and South Pole it's
like if you had if you have electricity
you could have something where the it
always would have a positive charge at
one end a negative charge at the other
end you you can never kind of saw it in
the electricity you can kind of saw it
in little and you can separate off this
is the positive charge this is a
negative charge for magnetism that isn't
possible you can't sort of soar off the
North Pole end of a magnet and have it
be its own separate magnetic monopole
they always come in pairs so at least
that's what seems to be the case in our
universe um it so the so what is
magnetism we can think of both
electricity and magnetism as being
features of this thing that's called the
electromagnetic field it doesn't really
help very much to say that because
that's just saying there's this thing
that's a combination of electricity and
magnetism I think it's probably fair to
say that it's just we just know about
physics that the that these this field
exists and what is true about it is when
there's a moving electric when there's a
moving when there's an electric current
and that is like going around in a
circle for example it makes a magnetic
field when there's a changing electric
field it makes some indirect field
it's also true that when there's a
changing magnetic field it makes an
electric field and that that fact about
when there's a change in one of these
fields it makes the other one that's
what allows you to have electromagnetic
waves of which light or radio waves are
two examples so I mean the the now if
you ask a question so since we've been
developing this fundamental theory of
physics you might ask how they are
twisted and magnetism work in that
fundamental theory of physics we
actually have a pretty decent idea of
how that might happen it's a little
complicated because it requires let's
think is there a way I can explain this
it's probably too complicated to explain
for now ask again in a few weeks we may
have a better explanation then um so so
anyway so but that's the the main thing
to remember is sort of an electric
current for example going in a circle
makes a magnetic field electric current
even in a wire just going in one line
makes a moving electric charge or an
electric current makes a magnetic field
and that's the way magnetic fields get
made electric current is just the motion
of electric charges there aren't
magnetic charges so far as we know so
magnetism works a little bit differently
all right there's a question here why is
the sky blue okay well let's see if we
can figure out a little bit about that
from just simple sort of thinking so
here are two facts we know the sky looks
blue and the Sun at sunset or sunrise
looks red so normally the Sun looks
white um we white light is made of a
combination of sort of all the colors of
the rainbow going all the way from red
through yellow green blue and and then
eventually to blue okay so red is at one
end blue is at the other end of the
rainbow and of the spectrum those when
we say those different colors are at
different ends what's happening is light
is made from we can think of it as being
made from a stream of photons and each
of those photons either a stream of
photons or electromagnetic wave of the
kind I was talking about and what
happens is blue light each electron has
a slightly higher energy than in red
light so each electron they they go at
the same speed they go at the speed of
light but the electrons can have
different energies and that means when
when the electrons can have different
energies and that means for example
they go when they interact with a camera
or something like that they can well
actually I'm I'm the I'm cheating a
little bit because that's not actually
how it works but I was going to say that
the photon can cause a little bit this
is this is roughly true the photon the
higher the energy the photon the the
larger amount of electricity it will
produce when there's a when there's a
detector like the retina in your eye or
the the detector in a webcam or
something the the roughly the higher the
energy of the photo and the larger the
electricity it will produce um the so
okay so every photon of light has a
certain energy the blue light has a
slightly higher energy than the red
light okay
so next we let's look at what happens
from the Sun the Sun is roughly white it
has a mixture of all these different
colors it has red photo has photons of
red light has photons of blue light
they're all coming to us from the Sun
okay so now let's let's ask the question
in order for the photons to get to us to
get to our eyes from the Sun they have
to go through the Earth's atmosphere
they have to go through the 50 miles or
so of air that exists as the atmosphere
around the earth okay so what happens
when that when the photons go through
the air well what happens is every so
often one of those photons will hit a
molecule of air hydrogen molecule
molecule oxygen molecule will hit one of
those molecules and it will be scattered
in some other directions so what happens
is the the photon comes in and the
photon just hits one of those molecules
and it will be made just like a billiard
ball or something bouncing off something
it will bounce and go in a different
direction okay so let's say we're
looking at UM at the Sun and we're
seeing it in the sky when we see it
there'll be a certain distance of air
that
is between us and the Sun so all the
photons that are coming from the Sun go
through that distance of air and so some
there'll be red photons blue photons etc
they all come to us okay at sunrise for
example the Sun is going through a
larger length of air than it is when the
Sun is high in the sky because we're
looking at it through we're kind of
looking at it like the atmosphere is
going around the earth and we're looking
further through the atmosphere when it's
at sunrise and if we're just looking
straight up and going sort of straight
out of the atmosphere we're looking kind
of along the along the surface of the
earth which means we're looking through
more atmosphere there
okay so what's happening then the light
from the Sun has to come to us through a
larger amount of air and when that's so
that means that that light the photons
that are in that light have more chance
to hit molecules in the air because
there's more air that they're going to
go through and so that some so that that
means that that um there's there's more
chance for those molecules to be
scattered that is to hit a molecule of
air and to be pushed off in another
direction okay so next fact is that blue
light higher energy photons have a
somewhat larger chance of being
scattered by air molecules and that is
not swell that's a phenomenon it's
called Rayleigh scattering and it could
probably explain to you why that happens
but let's just for now let's just take
that as a as a fact that if you're a
blue photon if you're a photon a blue
light which means slightly higher energy
photon then there's a higher chance that
you are scattered in a different
direction by hitting a molecule in the
air
okay so then light from the Sun is
coming to us you know at sunrise all
this white light mixture of red and blue
photons and so on is coming coming to us
but more blue photons are being
scattered away and so that means the
ones that actually make it to our eyes
are more likely to be red photons and
that's why the Sun looks redder at
sunrise and sunset it's going through
more air there's more chance for the
blue photons to be scattered
way so we don't see them and so instead
we're just seeing the red photons okay
so given this explanation you can
perhaps guess why this guy might be blue
because there's light coming from the
Sun and even when the Sun is high in the
sky there's still every photon that has
to come from the Sun has to come to us
it has to go through the air and what's
happening is the blue photons are being
more likely to be scattered off in
different directions and to essentially
be ones where will will they'll be
scattered as they come in from the Sun
then they'll be lets say scattered again
from another molecule early there and
then they'll get to our eyes and the
blueness of the sky comes from the fact
that there are photons that are coming
from the Sun and they're scattered out
of the way into a different part of the
sky and then they come to our eyes and
the ones where that happens more are the
blue photons so that's why the the sky
looks blue is because that's photons
coming from the Sun the red photons have
less chance to be scattered so they're
more likely to just go straight ahead
and not get scattered and so we just see
them as part of the whiteness of the Sun
unless they're going through a big
column of air as they do at sunrise or
sunset and then they then it will be the
the red ones that are more likely to
survive so the Sun will look red but the
things that aren't the Sun that are just
coming to that a light that can't come
directly from the Sun but gets scattered
out of the way by molecules in the air
then comes to us and then comes to our
eyes that's that's why the sky looks
looks blue now if you go up in a if you
go high enough up the sky will stop
looking blue because there isn't enough
there isn't enough air that the photons
have to come through that there's
significant scattering so if you for
example I remember once I went on the
Concorde supersonic plane which flew at
what was it fifty thousand feet maybe
I'm so a typical plane flies at 35,000
feet or so maybe a small plane might fly
a little bit higher than that um but
from the Concorde one of the cool things
was that was daytime flight but the sky
was black and the sky was black because
there wasn't in
air above one so that there were so that
the the photons from the Sun could be
scattered off in different directions
and the blue ones more than the others
and then scatter back to us and make the
sky seem to be blue so that's the story
um
why really scattering preferentially
scatters blue light maybe we can talk
about that another time um and uh that's
that's the answer to that um let's see
as a question here from Ethan
automatic a lower the the time needed to
make new vaccines let me explain what um
you know what is the vaccine doing a
vaccine
I explained a little bit about how the
immune system works what a vaccine is
trying to do is it's trying to say it's
trying to pretend that you are being
exposed to a particular virus or
whatever bacteria whatever to a
particular foreign genome sequence and
it's trying to pretend that and what it
wants to do is it wants to make your
immune system really wake up and say
gosh this is an intruder I've got to
build antibodies to that thing and I've
got to set up cells that will remember
how to build antibodies to that thing
but I've got to be I've got to do that
without you know without getting sick so
to speak so in other words it's got to
be the case that the vaccine presents
this intruders genome sequence and says
this is a bad genome sequence immune
system pay attention to this rather than
and that could happen if everyone got
sick with the disease there will be
billions of copies of that genome
sequence circulating all over your body
and the immune system will wake up and
say gosh this must be an intruder I've
got to pay attention to it but what
vaccines try to do is they try to trick
the immune system into thinking that
this is a really important sequence and
it must be an intruder go create a
antibodies to it
without having to have a very large
number of copies of that intruder
sequence and so they do that by having
additional molecules that activate the
more primitive part of the immune system
typically they do it this way at least
that sort of below the level of all of
the stuff about recognizing genome
sequences but that part of the immune
system is kind of an early warning
system that tells the main sort of
sophisticated immune system go pay
attention to what's happening at this
particular place at this particular site
where where a you know vaccine was
injected into your muscle or whatever
that's a place where there's something
really important going on immune system
go and check that out and don't make
antibodies to it okay so one of the many
issues is well first question is what
part of the
genome of the bacterium for the virus
for example do you put into the vaccine
that's one issue do you put and you know
to what extent is that little piece of
the virus something that is likely to be
well for example in the influenza virus
it changes there's a lot of mutation and
evolution in the influenza virus and
there isn't a universal flu vaccine
because nobody's found sort of a
sequence in the flu virus that is sort
of specific enough to flu viruses that
it couldn't get confused with something
that's in humans or some other thing
that is important to you but will be
always the same in every flu virus um
but the more important thing is that
this sort of thing that says to the
immune system go pay attention to this
particular place that is a tricky thing
and to get that to work is tricky to get
it to work without side effects to get
it to work so the immune system pays
enough attention it's all tricky what
people are hoping is that there will be
these sort of universal platforms for
making vaccines and that's what of the
vaccines that people are trying to the
covered 19 so the the corona virus those
vaccines are mostly being based on
existing sort of universal platforms
existing things where there's sort of a
a a standard method for where you just
say insert sequence here and then you
and then they'll sort of activate the
immune system in a certain way but it's
a tricky thing and I I think there's
this so another issue is once you think
you have a good vaccine how you test it
you want to make sure it doesn't give
people some nasty side effect you want
to make sure it's effective and I think
probably one of the areas where there's
in terms of sort of mathematical work
and the things that for example our
software tools are used for that they
used a bunch for the sort of the
molecular biology of these things but
but they're also used for studying the
sort of mathematical questions about how
do you really best do a trial of a
vaccine how many people do you test it
on how long do you have to wait you know
how sure are you that there aren't going
to be side effects
do you test it on a range of people of
different ages different you know
genders different this different that
different medical conditions and so on
how do you do all that testing how do
you kind of slice it up so that let's
say let's say you're eventually going to
give this vaccine to a billion people
you know you have to be quite sure that
it won't be the case if something went
wrong one in a million times so one in a
million people in a thousand people
it'll go wrong for them but you have to
try and guess whether something's going
to go wrong without having to give it to
those billion people first so you have
to do that by trying to figure out
what's the best sort of experiments you
can do try one person with these
characteristics one person with these
characteristics does it go wrong for
that does it go wrong for that can you
break these things apart that that's a
that's a typical kind of kind of problem
that has to be solved there so
gosh lots of questions here
um
as a question here from a Kevin say he's
currently a senior don't have much to do
just started with Mathematica to learn
how to program do you have any fun
projects or ideas that I could do during
this time you know a good place to get
some suggestions for that is if you go
look at our summer camp high school
summer camp for high school students I I
don't know where the senior I'm assuming
high school senior I'm the you'll find
the projects that have been done in in
previous years
go look at those projects and see if you
can find a a perhaps a variant on one of
those projects that seems interesting to
you
um the then another suggestion would be
go look at our demonstrations project
has about 12,000 interactive
demonstrations go find ones that you
think look interesting and make your own
better versions of things like that and
then send them into the demonstrations
project there's a couple of suggestions
um okay there's
let's see which one there's a lot of
interesting questions here all right
there's one just came in from Vance
how does Facebook know that I wanted a
new VR headset what I didn't tell anyone
okay that's an interesting question
so the
this whole question of of showing ads to
people what people want to do is to show
ads to people who are going to care
about what they're being shown as an ad
so for example if somebody shows me an
ad for I don't know cigars it's a wasted
ad because I've never had a cigar in my
life and don't ever expect to have one
so that ad is going to not be a useful
useful ad to show me if they show me an
ad for a VR headset will I actually have
a few of those already but maybe I might
be interested in that if they show me an
ad for a book about something about the
history of quantum mechanics or
something I might right now be really
interested in that that might be a real
a real good hit the question is how do
you how do you guess what kind of ad
I'll be interested in so basically you
have to know a certain amount about me
so what always used to happen when ads
mostly appeared in well their ads in
like newspapers ads and television shows
the idea there is okay let's say there's
a television show and it is a it's a
it's a baking show for example okay okay
then what you have to do is figure out
if people are watching the baking show
what kinds of things are they likely to
be interested in so for instance they're
watching a baking show there's a decent
chance they might be interested you know
kitchen utensils well they might be
interested in I'm showing my complete
ignorance of these things but they might
be interested in you know people
advertising things that you can use to
put in the stuff that you bake cookie
cookie mix or something there's a good
chance that that term that you'd be
interested in in something like that if
you're watching a baking show and you
know there's there's no particular
reason to believe that you will be
interested in vacations to the Antarctic
for example right so it really kind of a
waste to put an ad for a vacation with
the Antarctic
in the middle of a baking show similarly
if you if you have a you know a show
about you know travel through the
Antarctic it putting a thing about
cookie dough in that show is probably
kind of a waste right so so the thing is
if you have television shows for example
you try to get an idea of the
demographic the kinds of people who
watch that show and then you try to
figure out what kinds of ads are likely
to be relevant to those people so for
example if you for a television show or
something like that they the way that's
done is there is a sampling so some
people pick choose to say I'm going to a
there's a company called Nielsen for
example that term that gives people
these little boxes that kind of measure
every show that they watch and they know
something about those people and they
know what shows they're watching and so
they compile kind of information that
says this show that maybe you know
nobody necessarily knows you know when a
show is made they don't necessarily know
who's going to watch it and suddenly
that show may become popular among you
know I don't know thirteen-year-old
girls who like video games who knows and
that may be a demographic that that
develops for that show which the people
who created the show had no idea would
be would be relevant but but so what's
done for like a television show is
you're just sampling people who watch
the show and you're trying to compile
information on who watches that show
okay so that's sort of the traditional
model of advertising what's happened in
social media is something a little bit
more complicated which is that you're
the the information that exists about
you comes from what you look at it comes
from a variety of things but it comes
from what you look at in social media
it comes from things like who your
friends are what kinds of things you
post in social media all these kinds of
things so if you're posting a bunch of
stuff about some where you're let's say
you asked about a VR headset if you post
a bunch of things talking about virtual
reality then if if the system is
watching what you're posting then it can
say oh this is a person
in virtual reality okay I've got this
advertiser over here who says they're
looking for people who are interested in
virtual reality let's match them up and
have that ad shown to this person who
posted about virtual reality now of
course it's a very tricky issue because
the question of how you know how you
tell what somebody is really interested
in how the advertiser describes the set
of people that they want to reach it's
all quite complicated and you know
you'll find different companies Facebook
Twitter etc they use different methods
for allowing advertisers to pick who
they want to advertise to they also in
some cases there are well there's a
there's a lot of complicated things that
happen I mean there's a there's a lot of
things that personally are not a big
huge um I mean it's it's a it's it's
complicated to know what you know it's
it's a sort of artificial intelligence
system that's trying to figure out well
there are another issue which is
different advertisers will pay different
amounts of money for different for
having their ad reach different kinds of
people so for example the VR advertiser
might say I will bid 25 cents to show
this ad to a to a person with these
characteristics okay and another another
thing might say might be some I don't
know television show or might be some I
don't know what some I have no idea some
some other things some video game or
something will say I'll bid 30 cents to
show this ad to somebody with these
other set of characteristics and so
there's this complicated market that
happens that happens actually in real
time nowadays but for the ads actually
show up on your screen there will have
been this bidding that will have
happened where multiple advertisers will
have said that person I want to get
there then looking at my ad that person
they don't know who you are specifically
they don't know your name but they know
certain features about you and they're
trying to match up the features that
they know about you based on the posts
you made the friends you have all those
things with what they think their ad is
going to be be successful for him and of
course then they can measure if they if
they bid on a bunch of people have these
characteristics they can measure was
their ads successful with those people
or not how do they tell whether the ad
was successful
they tell because they can look at
whether you clicked on that ad so they
know directly it's much easier than for
example a television ad where they don't
really know directly whether whether you
respond at the ad I mean sometimes I
have to admit I don't watch television
really so I least used to be the case
and I may be way out of date that in
late night television there would often
be these direct response ads where
there'll be an ad for a thing and then
there would be a call this 800 number
now to get this thing and part of the
reason they were doing that was to
figure out first because they want to
sell the thing but also as they want to
know they know that in that 10 minute
period there was just this one ad that
was running and so they can measure
particular one ad in a particular part
of the country let's say so they can
measure what was the response to that ad
so a slightly long answer to that
question
um the I mean III would say that there's
a there's a very complicated story of of
kind of how how advertising works on the
internet I I could tell you in great
detail actually how it works and one of
the things that's a little bit
complicated is that the the because
there are certain networks that that put
run ads you might be looking at two
completely different websites and
knowledge about what you did on one
website might somehow magically seem to
be transported to another website the
reason that's happening is that both
websites are using the same ad network
and there are only a small number of
very large ad networks and so they're
getting information from and whether
this should be allowed is an interesting
question but you know you're looking at
one website over here and the ads from
that website the ad network that is
serving ads on that on that website is
storing information about you so even
when you're looking at another website
over here it's able to use the
information it got from when you looked
at the first website
um again not not completely obvious that
that should be something that is allowed
to happen but that's something that
uniformly does happen um okay let's see
um
gosh so many interesting questions here
well I'm going to take a couple here
okay how does a Space Station work um
well there's several different levels of
work so right now there's only one space
station that is actively in orbit around
the Earth the International Space
Station it's existed for I don't know
how long 25 years maybe um well the
first thing is it's in orbit around the
Earth so that means that the Earth's
gravity is pulling it in but it's going
fast enough about 17,000 miles an hour
that by the time it would have been
pulled in by Earth's gravity it's
already moved far enough that it sort of
it's sort of gone to the to the edge of
the earth so if it starts at the top
here it's kind of moving fast enough in
this direction that by the time it's
pulled down by this gravity
it's just pulled and it's it's gone to
the other it's gone around to the side
of the earth and so it just keeps going
in orbit around around the earth inside
the space station the so space is a
vacuum means it doesn't have any any air
in it there no air molecules or very
very few air molecules there's probably
around where the space station is I
would guess that there are I'm gonna
make a guess I'm not completely certain
but I'm gonna guess that they're on the
order of a maybe one air molecule in
every cubic centimeter whereas on on
normally let's think how many other well
there's maybe a billion trillion
molecules normally for us when we're
breathing air in in that term in that
and that size of of
of thing but but in space in space there
aren't any any molecules of air or
anything it's it's almost a perfect
vacuum so in order to be able to live on
the space station you have to there has
to be there has to be air there and all
it is is it's an enclosed box so to
speak an enclosed system that keeps the
air inside now again it's a little
complicated because the air that they
are that we breathe out we we breathe in
so the atmosphere is about 78% nitrogen
20% oxygen and the oxygen is what we use
in our lungs to that's that's what our
respiration is is making use of so when
we breathe in we are oxygen is getting
into our blood and that's that's what
allows our whole body to work when we
breathe in oxygen we breathe out carbon
dioxide and the and in this on the earth
there's a big sort of cycle where plants
effectively breathe in carbon dioxide
and produce oxygen and there's a sort of
big cycle that takes place where we are
exchanging where that gives us enough
oxygen to breathe on the space station
you have to have a similar kind of cycle
and you have to have you use you're not
you're not using plants using chemistry
to to to make that cycle work but you
have to you have to have such a cycle
because you don't you're not supplying
sort of tanks of oxygen the you know you
breathe in the oxygen you breathe out
carbon dioxide carbon dioxide is
molecules in which the carbon has been
attached to oxygen to carbon atoms of an
attack started in atoms chemical
processes can break those apart again so
that you again can have the oxygen to
breathe in so you have to kind of make
that cycle work um and that's kind of
the the main thing so the other thing
you need for example in a space station
is you need electric power and so you
don't you know how do you get the
electric power you
from big solar panels and there'll be a
big big sort of array of solar panels on
the on the international space station
solar panels same thing that you would
get in a solar panels on a house to get
some solar power the basic idea is that
when light from the Sun photons from the
Sun hit these some these pieces actually
of silicon in in it's sort of a silicon
with extra extra atoms in it in the in
the solar cell what's happening is
photon comes in it's got a bunch of
energy it kicks an electron out of kicks
an electron out to turn it into an
electron that can make an electric
current so the the photon comes in it
makes an electron sort of it kicks the
electron so that it goes off and makes
an electric current and that's
essentially how the electricity is being
made in a in a photovoltaic solar cell
thing and that's how the electricity is
made on the on the space station so you
know there's some other issues one might
ask the question if if one was going to
sort of send the space station off or
something like the space station off on
a six-month voyage to Mars or something
how would it's how would it work there
are new and different issues when you do
that for example the space station is in
low Earth orbit it's some there it is
not a subject to radiation ionizing
radiation things like x-rays gamma rays
other things that cause some cause
trouble for human cells and things as it
would be if it was in in deep space far
away from the earth although if there is
a a solar flare for example that can
produce a bunch of high-energy particles
that can cause trouble even for the
space station but that's so that's a
rough
um it's a rough thought on that okay
maybe we'll do one or two others and
then I should go here but um there's a
question here from crucial Ori do you
think math and algorithms plus graph
algorithm sauce graph theorists similar
how could somebody be good at one and
bad at the other you know math is a very
broad area actually you think of math as
being a narrow area but when you get to
the point of people doing math for
research for example it's actually quite
broad there are people where the thing
they're really good at is visualizing
geometrical objects and things there's
math where what people are really good
at is understanding kind of strings of
symbols and how those work there's math
where people are really good at sort of
the big picture of how these different
kind of abstract structures fit together
there's math where people are really
good at puzzle problem solving you know
how do these little puzzle pieces fit
together and so on it's it's a quite
broad area what you see in kind of
school math is somewhat narrower it's
much more focused on the more mechanical
kind of can you compute this thing you
know given this piece of algebra can you
work out what the answer is for this
algebra problem um you know when it gets
to things like when he gets to sort of
you get to higher and higher level math
it's less and less about this kind of
mechanical can you work out this than
that thing um and so for example in my
own case I think I was perhaps a little
overstated but I was I was certainly not
great at the more mechanical kind of
math I think my my lowest point was
probably I was about 10 years old when
the math I thought was just incredibly
boring and I just couldn't couldn't get
interested in it at all and and just
really didn't have the attention to to
to go work out you know how many you
know how many of these polynomials can I
expand or whatever um and but but it
turns out that being good at sort of
higher level math
is quite disconnected from that the one
thing you really learn and doing those
things is just how to do anything
precisely enough to get the right answer
because you know somebody asks you I
don't know um was this character in this
book good or bad
well you know they're probably a little
bit good a little bit bad it's kind of a
it's a it's it's an answer where you can
kind of just sort of discuss it but if
you say what is the answer from this
math problem the answer might be fifteen
or it might be eighteen and it's a
definite answer there's no well it's
roughly fifteen but it might be eighteen
type thing it's it's a definite answer
and it's really useful to learn how to
do things where you kind of have enough
sort of mental organization and sort of
ability to be precise about things that
you can actually go ahead and know yes I
got the answer it's 15 I got it right
it's exactly right
it's not where I got it roughly right
and maybe my teacher liked me so they
gave me a good grade but I don't really
know where I got it completely right
because it's all kind of vague so you
know math has this nice feature that
it's it's definite and that's in that
level actually programming and things
with computers algorithms and so on also
have that feature it's definite at that
level one thing that's nice about the
programming case is that you know you're
typing a piece of Wolfram language code
or something it's supposed to produce a
you know a map of the US but actually it
just produces a pink box okay the
computer told you whoops you did
something wrong so you can go back and
say what did I do wrong let me try and
figure it out you try and fix it
eventually kaboom it makes the map of
the US or whatever it is um and that's
kind of a nice feedback loop it's
actually in many ways I think it's a
nicer feedback loop than what you have
to have to have in math where it's kind
of like you know teacher says answer is
wrong with you necessarily there's not
the sort of satisfaction of you know yes
you just managed to communicate with the
computer you managed to actually get it
to do what you wanted it to do and there
it gives you the answer it's you know
it's it's gone and undone this so I
think the now you know when it comes to
programs the well the biggest problem of
writing programs is making mistakes if
if every program you wrote if you could
always take well actually though I
should say a different thing the very
beginning problem of writing a program
is what do you want the program to do
you have to be able to conceptualize
what it is you want from this program
and how you can break down what you want
into something you can explain to the
computer it's a little bit like in in
math they're kind of these word problems
where you're given you know some sort of
description and words and you'll have to
turn that into math but the computer
case is actually I think a much better
case of that because it's something
where you kind of might know oh I want
to have the thing work I want it to do
this you have something in your mind you
wants it to do maybe it's something you
wanted it to do it's not an exercise
it's not something from school it's just
something you wanted it to do you have
it in your mind and maybe you realize at
some point gosh it actually isn't quite
the right thing that I want it let me
change a little bit what I wanted it to
have the computer do and then you go off
and figure out how to tell the computer
that as well but so first thing is how
can you take from what you think you
want the computer to do break it down in
a form where the computer could could
have the potential to understand then
you have sort of the mechanical process
of explaining it to the computer you
know I've spent a large part of my life
trying to make it as easy as possible
for people to explain things to
computers to have a language a
computational language that us humans
can kind of wrap our brains around as
well as possible but the computers can
also understand and where the computer
is doing as much of the work as possible
and where you just have to be able to
sort of crispin up your thinking to the
point where you can express it in our
computational language and then feed it
to the computer ok so that's that's sort
of the the beginning of how you how you
get a computer to do things well then
the problem is weren't particularly you
write larger programs the problem is you
make mistakes why do you make mistakes
because it's
but difficult to figure out all possible
implications of a program you write
turns out one of the things I discovered
scientifically many years ago and its
really an important thing that sort of
fed into this work on fundamental theory
of physics now is even really really
tiny programs can do really complicated
things so even though you say this is a
tiny program I got to be able to
understand what it does well no sorry
there's a sort of theoretical scientific
reason why even though the program may
be very small it may do really
complicated things which you can't
foresee and so it isn't you shouldn't be
embarrassed that you make mistakes in
programs because programs will the the
sort of a program even though it may be
quite a small program may have may have
has the potential to do things that are
so complicated there's no way you could
possibly foresee those things and so
that's kind of the the theory of bugs
and programs you know you write a
program you say I think I've thought of
all the things this program could do but
no you you really won't have been able
to in many cases and you know in in the
early days when people are first
inventing the idea of programming nobody
had this idea of bugs nobody thought
that would happen
nobody had conceptualized this point
that it was sort of inevitable that
programs would have sort of things that
you wouldn't be able to foresee but but
they do and so then when you write
programs one of the goals of people like
me language designers is to make it as
as easy as possible as well to make it
so that it is so that the correct
programs programs that will do what you
want are the most natural programs to
write that that we're kind of leading
you to write a program that is likely to
do what you want as opposed to making it
really difficult you have to really kind
of stand in your head to get the program
to be what you want and but it's really
easy to make a program that will do
something you probably don't want the
goal of one of the goals of language
design is to make it so that you're
you're you're typically going to do this
I mean it's like if you're making a
mechanical device and you want people to
you want it to be easy to press the stop
button make the stop button a big red
button don't make the stop button this
little weird thing you have to open up
and do this and that and then you hit
the stop button the goal is make the
things you might want to do and you
might want to do you know that make them
as easy as possible and that's a goal of
language design that's kind of the
responsibility people like me to make it
as easy as possible for people to write
correct programs but nevertheless as
soon as the things you want the program
to do can get it all complicated it is
inevitable that there'll be places where
you can't foresee what it will do and
there may be a bug in your program so
this process of debugging a program is
an interesting intellectual exercise
it's an interesting intellectual process
it's it's very much easier in our
Wolfram language computational language
then it has typically been because our
language is a higher-level language the
things the individual things you're
doing in it are much bigger and sort of
within each piece it's gonna do the
right thing it's the question is did you
assemble the pieces correctly it also
has a feature that in technical terms
that's a symbolic language which means
that any piece of the program you can
sort of take out and use on its own in
most sort of low level programming
languages it's not a trivial thing to
take a little tiny piece of a program
out and see what it does in our language
it happens to be very easy and that's
kind of the first step in debugging a
program is okay you see it did something
wrong go and well first of all you sort
of instrumented and say what are you
doing inside program and have it print
out and say I'm doing this I'm doing
this I'm doing this you say oh well that
piece you got wrong so you go and you
take that piece of the program out and
you look at it on its own and you say
did that do the right thing or not um
and then if it didn't and it's a little
tiny program you have a better chance to
go and look inside and see you know oh
why did it do the wrong thing and
eventually say aha I realize why I did
the wrong thing
now people there is huge variation in
people's ability to do debugging the
programs it's a it's a strange skill I
don't know what it's correlated with but
some people are really quite good at it
and some people are not I think the the
typical thing is well first of all it's
a think without assumptions because as
soon as you think you know what's going
on the chances are you'll not notice the
thing that's actually going
so that's one one kind of thing it's
also a kind of a logical sort of
deduction type thing I mean it's it's
very program debugging is something that
um well it's sort of they're related
things there's debugging your programs
there's debugging of computer systems
you know why did my computer's audio not
work or something and there's sort of a
completely different area which is
medical diagnosis you know why do I have
some symptom that exists in you know
some medical symptom that exists these
are three kinds of thinking that are all
actually I think rather related and
they're they're interesting they're very
interesting sort of and they're very
different
it's different from a lot of what one
normally does and it's it's some it's
really it's really interesting to try
and learn to be good at these things and
for example debugging programs as I say
this don't make any assumptions about
what's going on just look at the look at
what it's doing try and figure out you
know why did it do what it did
don't say from the beginning well if you
get very experienced you will start
getting intuition of what kind of a
problem it is you won't know what the
problem is but you'll know what kind of
a problem it is um it's the same thing
you know experienced doctors get an
intuition about what kind of a problem
something is likely to be um it's some I
think that the so so you know but this
this process so you're asking I think
the original question was why would
people be so good at math bad at
algorithms good at algorithms bad at
math they're both pretty diverse areas
so there's a lot of different things in
math there's a lot of different things
to do with with programming and
algorithms and so on and I think it's
you know the what where there's overlap
is is is is not clear and I think that
one of the things that happens is well
in in math there's different kinds of
math you can do you know there's for
example in my own case I'm um I'm not
great at visualizing 3d shapes like if
you asked me you know what um what would
be the I don't know some
you know imagine an icosahedron and
imagine this and and what how does the
edge of this go to that go to this go to
that I'm not very good at that one of my
kids my older daughter is really good at
that I remember from when she was very
young just some question came up and
she's just sitting the back of the car
or something and some question about
polyhedra comes up and she's like oh
yeah there's a line that goes from here
to there and it's like how do you figure
that out well he can visualize it I
can't visualize it she can she's now a
math graduate student so that kind of
you know that that was that line but but
um I think that the you know different
people are good at different things I
mean there's plenty of math that
somebody like me can do even though I'm
really pretty useless at sort of the 3d
visualization you know what does how
does this shape look just in one's
mind's eye so to speak
and so I think it's it's you know it's
very it's more a question of what do you
want to do in these areas do you like
what comes out from doing math do you
like understanding these abstract
structures do you like the puzzle
problem solving of math you know if you
like these things then there's a good
chance that there's a there's a sort of
a part of that that you'll discover that
you're good at all right I think we
should wrap up here and I thank you all
for joining us there were a bunch of
other interesting questions which I was
sorry I didn't get to UM and I hope
we'll have a chance to do this again
probably next week we will pick a
different focus topic um and look
forward to seeing you all then okay
thanks bye